oh my gosh here we are we are gearing up
more vacay i love it i love it now the
trailer is getting us
so new episodes it says
get ready for a vacation you won't sure
get
so please tell us what is so
unforgettable about
this vacation with all y'all
so many so many things vinnie you take
it away with your talent show
i mean hilarious i feel
um any time that we have to be in these
like coveted bubbles with each other
um it really brings out our creative
side and
we kind of like we do a lot you know
because we're not
interacting with the outside world
anymore so instead we're
creating our own talent shows we are
doing general parties
baby showers
we created wrestlemania this time like
we got a full-blown
wrestling ring and we wrestled like it
was crazy it's amazing what you can
actually pull off
in a bubble like we didn't really go
anywhere but we just brought everything
in this time
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen parties here
and especially with y'all last time you
brought in uncle nino for the wedding
this time around you're bringing in
snooki snooki yeah
snack so what was it like having her
back on vacation with you
i feel like she like never left like
with vinnie says all the time like
and also i was really happy to have her
back because we needed to have that sit
down and also she's my drinking partner
so to have her back and have her like
somebody to let loose
with me and just have cocktails with me
and be like stupid
that's something that i really look
forward to when i see nicole yeah what
about you guys
so how crazy did things get when snooki
came back into the mix
vinnie yes she she picked up right where
she left off and she had a lot of making
up to do because she missed a few
episodes so she put all that
turn up in one episode when she came
back and the whole time that were with
her she was just on
fire but it was great to have the whole
gang back again because that was the
first time
we've been all together in a long time
so it was just dope having everybody
we were great like um you know we were
still rocking and rolling
in lake las vegas and everything so just
adding snooki back into the mix was just
like another
added bonus like she came in and now the
family was whole again
when we're together we're like we're
like a a recipe you know and you need
like every little ingredient to make the
recipe the best
i love seeing you all back in the mix
and can't wait to see how it all plays
out
but tell me this vinnie did you get can
you give us a little intel as to why
snooki wanted to return i know she
needed a break
can totally understand it but why did
she come back that's a good question
i actually never got that follow i knew
why she left
yeah i knew why she left um maybe she
like was able to kind of recharge a
little bit
this is like real life so sometimes we
all have had to step away from the show
and deal with our own real world stuff
and i think she did that and then she
was just ready to come back yeah and
speaking of vinnie
look we have truly seen it all over the
course of
jersey shoreditch jersey shore family
vacation because it is a reality show
we've seen the good
the bad the ugly the real ugly so
how is it that you continue to be able
to stick by one another through all of
those times vinny
well i mean look we're like a family now
these people have become more of a
family to me than like
i don't want to say like my own family
but like i see them
more than a lot of my own family but at
the same time it's like
the last season it showed us that we can
be ripped apart sometimes
and i never want to go through that
again we took like a whole year to
reconcile that and now this new season
is about
being back together leaning on each
other we're going to have drama with the
outside world of course
and our own lives but together we're
like a whole family again
awesome good to hear that now speaking
of the whole family
the cast recently took home the mtv
movie and tv award
reality royalty award so congrats on
that front
thank you you know polly tell me this
why is it after all
seasons and all these years the fans
keep coming back for more of the jersey
shore
well if i had to take a guess at that um
i'm really
happy that we won that award but um as
to why people watch i think that
they relate to us we go through real
world things and we actually document it
i mean
everything you can think of from
weddings to divorces
to jail to birthdays to babies all that
stuff and we documented so
even if um you started watching from the
beginning you get to grow up with us and
see our families growing bigger and
bigger and bigger
and um relate to that and the people
that don't relate to it it's
entertaining to them i think
yeah yeah and without a doubt without a
doubt man
yeah now you were talking babies you
were talking weddings you know we've
seen angelina get married
we've seen spooky j well you know
they've been having all these babies and
everything
yeah as well so vinnie
yeah your cats having them babies
they're getting married as well
so does that ever give you the itch to
maybe ditch your single status
well um i just filmed a new season of
double shot at love
so i'm sure we'll be talking again soon
so you don't know what my single what my
status is right now
um so you may not you're not single
i don't know i can't say ah
i don't get the itch i mean i i like to
live vicariously through them
um it's fun to hold their babies and
then when they start crying i give the
babies back
yeah um and you know like uh i'm not
i'm 33 i'm not just gonna settle down to
settle down like i would have to meet
the right person that
and when it's time for me i'll do it
fair enough i like that answer that's
solid
paulie how's your relationship going
these days man
oh it's going well um you know the
pandemic helped us
out it actually kept me put for the a
good period of time and give a
relationship the attention it needed
and um i enjoy having her around i enjoy
her company we're still just taking it
day by day and uh
keeping it just that for now angelina
has had three fiances
oh my god angelina any chance in the
upcoming episodes we'll see
a redo to the redo of the wedding or did
the guys do okay
they did so good vinnie killed it with
that redo speech
angelina i know that the last speech
was a little bit rocky
but thank you for calling the master
speech writer
to give a speech and to show you all how
to really roast somebody
and how it's done i mean i still laugh
about it to this day
such an idiot but hilarious um yeah
you'll see a lot of how many redos can
she have
eventually it's just going to be a
divorce i think oh shut up
some people call her the staten island
dump well joke's on them because the
staten island dump has been closed for
several years and now it's a beautiful
park that people love to go to
it's true i didn't think of it like that
beachgate
by the way you'll see a lot of my
relationship play out on this new season
um
can't really give much away but you'll
see that like the pandemic was not
amazing to my relationship put it that
way
but you are still wearing that ring i
see angelina i am
i am okay well i hope you
it depends on the day it depends on the
day
i'm getting my [ __ ]
[Music]
you